quelle taille avait homme et femme au
Moyen-Âge l'école existait-elle comment
se repérer-t-on les réponses se trouvent
dans l'exposition un petit tour au
Moyen-Âge à Élancourt
les enfants peuvent découvrir mille ans
d'archéologie et d'histoire le but c'est
pas un exercice c'est pas un devoir
c'est vraiment d'y prendre du plaisir et
de sentir ce qui était la vie des
habitants d'Élancourt et des Yvelines au
Moyen-Âge ou au Moyen-Âge puisqu'on
divise le moyen-âge en deux en deux
époques mais pour cela on a voulu
vraiment qu'il y ait une interaction
entre l'exposition et celui qui l'a
visite entre les enfants et l'en
courtois et ce monde du Moyen-Âge
l'exposition est ludique un petit tour
au Moyen-Âge permet aux visiteurs de
toucher sentir et entendre tout ce qui
se passait à cette époque
et après qu'on y est pas la guerre tous
les jours et que
et que il y avait des vivants dans les
cimetières
beaucoup de choses effectivement que les
gens vivaient pas si mal que ça
finalement à certaines périodes du
Moyen-Âge voilà et puis bon qu'ils
étaient pas tout à fait comme nous
effectivement plus petit en taille en
pointure que il mangeait pas comme nous
non plus et qui avait des des légumes
qui qui n'existaient pas et qu'on en a
aujourd'hui comme la pomme de terre le
poivron des choses comme ça quoi
comment se laver ton que cuisiner ton
les enfants lisent les réponses et
apprennent en soulevant les panneaux de
cette exposition proposé jusqu'au 27
février par le Conseil Général également
mis en place des maquettes qui évoquent
des scènes de bataille et de la vie
quotidienne l'exposition est seulement
ouverte le samedi après-midi